hello everyone
yes we can hear your doctor okay good
afternoon everyone
uh it's nice to be on this platform this
time of the day and uh i'm very glad
that we are collaborating with omislogic
uh the platform prime biotech
and for these upcoming course that is
starting next week
which is tagged as application of
microboom and
meta genomics analysis in life sciences
next slide please
[Music]
yeah bioinformatics what we do at elix
as you have seen we train we support and
provide bioinformatics services to meet
the need of researchers
we have bioinformatics analysis and
planning we do data management and
analysis
we offer workshops and training on
various bioformatic topics for
researchers and institutions
and that is one of the things that is
ongoing now because we are collaborating
with a known and reputable organization
that has been involved in bioinformatics
training
and we provide resources and allies
services for various research
projects now i'll be talking on
metagenomics
metagenomics is the study of metagenome
genetics materials recover directly from
environmental samples
such as soil water or physics and some
other things
why microbiome is a study of metagenome
genetic material recovered directly from
humans or animals
then how can we apply this metagenomics
to let you know that this training we're
about starting is very very essential
for you
for anyone it can be applied in
agriculture
in energy food and nutrition
biotechnology
biosensor environment other industries
medical miss nanos i have one of the
work
i lay my hand on as regards to
agriculture that i discovered that a
metagenomics analysis of a soy sample
can guide us on the appropriate crop
to be planted on it and this is
a an essential training
that i employ all of us to take part in
it
because it is very very important thank
you once again
uh viewers i think you can take up the
lead again
thank you so much
for your kind words and for organizing
this workshop along with us
i would now like to say
a few words about our omics logic team
and our collaborators have made this
training possible my name is peepsha
biswas
and i am the omits logic community
manager responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users
like you who are part of our
bi-informatics community
managed by fine biotech over the course
of the past several years our team has
been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
all around the world that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design as
a result
the omits logic programs have been
thoroughly evaluated
and lead to excellent outcomes
the goal of the omics logic programs is
to provide training
in bioinformatics enabling independent
research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of
all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
omix logic metagenomic training program
will be guided by trainers who have
ample experience with bioinformatics in
both academic and industry applications
i will now invite elia brodsky our ceo
of spine biotech to speak about
metagenomic sequencing and the upcoming
program
over to you elia thank you very much
pizza
and welcome everybody to this webinar
i'm excited to participate in this
webinar because
i think that the microbiome provides
something
thank you very much so please keep your
microphones muted so that we can all
participate here so metagenomics i think
is an exciting opportunity because it
really provides a snapshot
into how
these communities that live
and function together as almost like an
organ could be studied using next
generation sequencing so we can
gain insight into composition species
diversity and richness
and understand the functional
applications of metagenomics so in the
context of this program
we're going to find different examples
where we will see the application of
microbiome
we will learn how to analyze metagenomic
data
gain insight from data by mapping it
onto reference databases
and we will guide you on how to select a
project of your own
that could relate to either clinical
psychological maybe soil and
environmental samples
so we'll provide a number of curated
data examples for you to choose from
to work on a project of your own so
let's talk a little bit about the
history of metagenomics why
is metagenomic sequencing such an
impactful technology
so bacteria or the microorganisms in
general have been discovered back
in the 1800s in fact when
bacteria was discovered to cause
different pathogenic functions in
clinical diagnostics
the first way to study bacteria was to
culture it in the lab
and so with the invention of the
microscope when the microorganisms have
been detected
then through culturing we understand how
bacteria
different strains of bacteria could have
a major impact but today
with the advent of next generation
sequencing
we can study these microorganisms
without
isolating them in the lab and culturing
them we can actually study the full
composition of the communities that they
live in and a big part of understanding
those communities
relates to the study of the microbiome
using
computational technology so when we say
metagenomics
we're really talking about analysis of
metagenomic data
using computational tools now as many of
you probably know from personal
experience study the studying the
microbial communities
and trying to address how those
communities
colonize different parts of our bodies
is really something that requires
an understanding of how they function
and grow together so here we have an
example
of skin and in the pores of the skin you
can see how this bacteria can
colonize forming a film
which is very difficult to wash off
and disrupt and that is one of the
properties of the microbiome
that they form this relationship with
the host
and learn how to form a film
that is difficult to wash off and
difficult to remove
because it is integrated into the
epithelium
and so when you think of that property
of the microbiome
and you start thinking about different
surfaces and organs that this film can
develop on
we now have over 80 000 different
publications
about the microbiome function in
different places of the body
so here you can see a few examples of
how diverse these communities can be
but typically a distinct microbiota
a community of the microbes is formed
by dominant bacteria that you can see
here a few examples of those dominant
bacteria
and composition which means that
proportions
are stable and those proportions could
be disrupted
by different conditions and
challenged by different environmental
challenges
and we'll talk about that in a few
moments but what's interesting
is that in those 80 000 publications or
more that have been published on the
role of microbiome
more than half of those relate to the
gut
microbiome now the gut microbiome as
is fairly obvious is the densest
community of microbiota in our bodies
and that's
also a and that is also a the easiest
community of sample because we can take
fecal samples so we can observe
fecal microbiota throughout the lifetime
of a person it's easy to sample it's
easy to analyze because
we have such a clear access to that
at the same time there have been some
recent studies
that have shown that that is not the
only microbiome that plays a huge role
in a variety of different conditions so
let me go through some examples as you
can see here on the screen
this is a timeline of major microbiome
sequencing initiatives
that start around just after the
sequencing of the human genome
and so one of those is obviously the
major the gut microbiome but then
additional ones include the skin the
lung and even the brain
microbiome so the lung microbiome
the microbiome of the lung has less
bacterial biomass so
it has less proportion of bacteria as
compared to the gut
but it displays a considerable diversity
the composition of the lung microbiome
is determined by
elimination immigration and relative
growth within its community so when you
think of the microbiome of the lung
imagine that certain bacteria are easier
to come in leave
the lung area and so we can
see the difference for example in
chronic conditions so many forms of
chronic lung disease demonstrate
exacerbations that drive disease
progression
and are now poorly understood but
there's growing evidence that supports
ways in which microbiota dysbiosis or
the disorder
can influence the host defense and
immunity
and in turn may contribute to disease
exacerbations
it is key to understanding the
pathogenesis of chronic lung disease
that may reside in deciphering the
complex interactions between the host
the pathogen and resident microbiota
during stable disease and exacerbations
so lung is a major microbiota that is
continuous that continues to be studied
extensively
the brain is a novel area
of microbiome studies over the past
decade
the development of these sequencing
technologies have enabled extensive
characterization
of microorganisms including in the gut
lung skin and now in the brain and so
because we know that the microorganisms
that we coexist
with can influence our physiology immune
system
even behavior we know that the brain
could be affected by dysbiosis or
changes in the microbiome
but previously it has been thought that
the brain is a sterile
environment protected from bacteria and
other
pathogens and so now there's first
evidence
that has shown that in fact microbiome
of the brain
could be affected so i want to point you
to an
article there is
actually a discussion in the literature
around the role of the brain microbiome
and here you can see some evidence
of sequencing reeds mapped to individual
bacterial presence so this is very
interesting because
as i mentioned the brain was considered
to be a sterile environment so
not only that we also know that there
are other types of microbiota
changes related to different diseases
and i think this is
a very exciting field and as we can see
here
there is a growing number of
publications continuingly is
expanding to offer us insights into
a variety of different types of
microbiomes
so you can see that about 20 percent
of u.s investment in research
has gone to two phases of the human
microbiome project
which is creating the research resources
needed to study
the human microbiome in different areas
of the body in the different organs
and the goal of this human microbiome
project launched in 2007
is to create a toolbox of reference data
sets
computational techniques analytical
methods and
clinical protocols so we can see how
the investment in developing novel
technologies
and also an understanding of what
microbiome
is and how it plays a role in human
disease has
also enabled us to ask very specific
questions
about the role of the microbiome which
actually play a major role even in the
current pandemic so here you can see
an example of recent studies about the
role of microbiome
in uh the infection and it is
hypothesized
that the changes in the microbiota have
an association with more severe disease
progression of covid19 so it's a very
interesting correlation
at the same time this pandemic
intersects with a decade-long decline
in microbial diversity and ancestral
microbes due to
hygiene antibiotics and urban living
because of the hygiene hypothesis so
what has happened
over the past several decades more
people live in cities
there's more uniform level of
sterilization
access to sterilized food access to
antibiotics and different treatments
that reduce the overall
diversity of the microbiome as a result
the hypothesis
is that our body is less exposed to the
diversity
that could be very important to train
our immune system to recognize
different pathogenic microbes so the
current pandemic control measures and
practices
are hypothesized to have an even broader
and potentially long-term effects on the
human microbiome right so there's so
much
uh sterilization of hands there's so
much protection from the air that we
breathe
and the different public public
situations that we visit so how will
this affect
the long-term immunity is a question
that needs to be studied
and so much is still uncertain or
unknown about the virus and how it's
going to affect
humans in the future but we understand
that we need to start investing now
in our understanding of the role of the
microbiome
and how it will go through with this
pandemic
so to summarize the function of the
microbiome
is to help with the differentiation and
the development of the immune system
to assist with food digestion and
nutrition to
perform energy generation in
conservation help with
metabolic regulation of fat storage
process environmental chemicals
maintain the skin and the mucosal
barrier and the prevent
prevention of invasion by pathogen so
these different functions in terms of
the human health are
critical when we study the microbiome
how can the microbiome be studied it
could be studied with
two primary technologies that are
available
today sequencing and mass spectrometry
so when we speak about sequencing we can
look at
particular pathogens that are either
isolated
or by sequencing everything that is in
the microbiome mapping it onto the
reference dna
or we can also analyze meta
transcriptome
when we think about what products
are going to be produced by these
microbes
when we speak about mass spectrometry
we're really talking about detection
of particular metabolites or
proteins that could be analyzed by their
mass composition so we can look at these
spectra and
design assays to study what products
are and what signaling pathways occur in
these diverse and complex communities
so one of the technologies that we will
focus on in this program
is metagenomics where we will look at
the composition as i mentioned before
the difference between different
other types of omix technologies and
metagenomics specifically
is that while other types of omix
technologies are focused on
studying a single organism a system
here we are going to study how
communities
of microorganisms form a distinct
functional community
and what does the dysbiosis or the
change in that composition
tell us about the condition that it
produces
and so here you can see an example of
two ways of studying
the microbiome either looking at
operational taxonomic units
that we can characterize the composition
or culturing and still use sequencing to
understand
what amount of different areas in the
on this genome are being produced so
we'll talk about these different ways of
studying metagenomic data
and we will also learn about how to
prioritize
different hypervariable regions
in the metagenomic sequencing data so
that we can accurately detect
how different communities that have not
all been
annotated could still be studied for
composition so we'll talk about
the taxonomic classification
of bacteria using the 16s
ribosomal rna and the understanding of
taxonomy as far as composition
in different organs of the body and
comparison between different organs
in different conditions so ultimately
our goal with the analysis of sequencing
data
is to be able to apply the sequencing
data
to understand the host response to study
the microbiome that includes the
bacteria
and the viruses that are present in the
bacteria
and associate those with clinical or
phenotypic data and so that will be the
ultimate goal of this program
and we will see how similar and now
analytical thinking and logic applies to
the study of omics data and integration
of that omix data
for clinical and uh
therapeutic application so that would be
one of the primary
objectives for this program
uh let me briefly mention a few project
examples that we're going to be using
we have prepared a number of curated
data sets
publications that have been digested and
turned into tutorials
and we will discuss these at different
stages of the program so one of those i
mentioned already the human
microbiome project one of those is
a part of that human microbiome project
is called the american gut project
it's a citizen science project where we
will learn how to take that data
and generate a report just like what you
see right here
this is a report that is produced by the
american gut project participants
and where you can see the diversity
of different sample composition
and comparison to other types of samples
that
are similar to yours and you can also
compare those to
multiple tissues in the body ages and
populations
and other factors we will also talk
about
the gut brain axis or how gut microbiota
can affect our levels of anxiety and
behavior
and we will talk about methods of
elucidating specifically the role of the
microbiome
by focusing on animal models so in
animal models what is useful is that we
can study
how distinctly a pro a portion
of this complex system so
just the microbiota affects different
types of behavior so you can see here
that even though we can get insights
from patient data in
animal studies we can design mechanistic
studies
that will really illustrate what is the
role of the microbiome
and how that applies to a variety of
interventions
interventions using diet interventions
using
different types of antibiotics
intervention
using exercise and other factors
and it's important because anxiety is
just an
insight into overall psychological
conditions
and even clinical conditions that arise
potentially as a result and having an
impact
by the microbiome so here's an example
of
china approving the first alzheimer's
treatment
that targets the microbiome and you've
probably heard of many
other examples of interventions using
fecal transplantation and other types of
interventions so here we see a number of
cancer therapies that have proposed to
be
affected by the microbiome composition
and therefore we understand how the
metabolic potential of these microbes
and the products that they
produce is an important area of study
for us to have
more personalized and more effective
treatments
for different types of patients now as
was mentioned already before me it's not
only
that the microbiome is affecting human
health
and disease we also will talk about
microbiome in
agriculture so how can we actually study
the composition of soil and
different bacteria that live on the
roots of plants
so there are there's the soil microbiome
the bacteria and the microorganisms that
live in the soil
and then there's also specific
communities that form around the root
nodes
and those are play a major role in the
way that the plants can absorb different
nutrients and interact with the
environment
and so we'll look at examples where the
interaction
and the composition of these microbial
communities
can play a role on the production
capacity so how much fruit is being and
plants how well they grow how resistant
and resilient they are
in different harsh conditions and also
as was mentioned how to select
the best soil for different crops and
for different objectives
so i hope that this will be an
interesting program for all of you to
consider joining
and to speak about how to join this
program
i want to pass it on to dr mohit
mazumner
who will guide you through the
registration process
thank you ilya yeah so
i'll just share my screen
okay hello everyone my name is mohit
mazumda i'm one of the global
representatives of pine biotech
and our mission here is to simplify
complex bioinformatics research
and reach out to the student and
research community
to participate in advanced data-driven
biological research
through our modular and intuitive uh
multi-omics t-band for platform
and our coding and educational
portals
so this program omics logic metagenomics
it is a specialized program
that not only takes you through the live
sessions courses
example publications and data sets but
also gives you an unique opportunity to
apply this knowledge to a real
metagenomics project
so as in all of our omics logic training
programs we will be leveraging online
we will be leveraging online sessions
such as these but
more more towards uh uh hands-on
activity
and then we will be also using
self-guided materials
and that are carefully and there have
been
validatedly designed and taken by
thousands of students
across different groups
and then we have practical assignments
and tutorials
that you can take to learn and go
deeper into these methodologies and
techniques
so this entire entire experience
is omics logic is is in the omixlogic
training
program sorry
okay so this online program is uh
equally rewarding rewarding for students
and researchers and specially suited for
project based learning
on a flexible schedule so all of these
sessions that we will be having for this
program
will be pre will be recorded and will be
emailed to our participants
other than that the program will cover
main aspects of
metagenomic sequencing analysis of 16s
rna and other aspects of microbiology
research
using bioinformatics so in these
sessions we will do hands-on
uh hands-on uh hands-on
experience using the tbi info platform
and also we will practice through our
codomix logic platform
and then we will learn about uh how you
know 16s metagenomic
data is processed and that results in a
table of annotated
16s rrna genes and then you can
read those map counts and that's that
table
that could be annotated by taxonomical
levels like
uh kingdom family genus species so
learning about
all those through hands-on experience
that we will be doing
through all these uh sessions along with
the materials
that will be shared with you as a form
of courses as form of
example projects or example
example publications so at the end of
this program
participants will be conducting an
independent
and there will be an opportunity to
conduct whether
an independent or a or a
group project where you will be able to
work on publicly
available data sets and learn from the
and learn about the impact of this
publications and the research on the
microbiome
so the sessions will be around uh the
same time
of 5 p.m to 6 30 p.m
west african time
[Music]
so our metagenomics bioinformatics
research training and that what we are
discussing today and all of you
have joined to learn about uh is a
research training which is
well structured and it has been
recognized by
experts from academia and industry as
well
so talking more about like how this
program would be
and what what these resources are that
i'm talking about
so this specialized training involves a
lot of project
examples because learning by doing
is one of the best ways to learn so
starting from a level 0
or design for beginners
so introduction to metagenomics you'll
start from a
basic level where you learn about the
keywords and the application
how this field has evolved to a advanced
level
where you will be further supplemented
by publication
a publication derived project examples
that are available
as educational projects so the
educational projects
are tutorials that explains a
peer-reviewed
published research project in a
simplified manner
and explains the data set to next
work on the analysis using the t by info
platform
so that will be uh the part of this
program and we will be doing that
by uh also showing you how to do that so
these are already described
in the courses and in the project
examples and then
we will have the live sessions to
supplement that and to answer your
questions
or the problems that you have faced or
any of those issues
that would be addressed so one of the
biggest uh you know uh advantage of this
program
is just that the for those along with
the zoom
sessions you get a very important aspect
of
mentor support so our omics logic
programs are supported by experts
and they have a rich experience and rich
background
in both industrial and academic
bioinformatics research projects
and both in education and training
so i think uh most of you have uh
joined today's join today session have
an interest in metagenomic research
so i just wanted to talk a little bit
about metagenomic research and i know
easily i did talked about the
metagenomic research in length
so um so this research field it's a
newer field
of biological research and it has
already
impacted us so i just wanted to
show you some examples so
that recent study about the gut
microbiome and kovid 19
that ilia talked about so the uh
one of such study is like where the
author concluded that the
individual gut microbiome may affect the
body response to subscribe to infection
uh which means like the gut
gut bacteria might influence both
short and long term effect of the
infection and how the gut microbiome can
affect uh brain health in the case of
uh neurodegenerative diseases that might
lead to you know better and
easier treatment for brain diseases
another example is this uh segmented
filamentous bacteria in gut so in green
you can see they are over simulated
uh the brain the immune system of a
pregnant mice that have done that have
an infection
so that altered its uh fetus
brain development so that's one of the
aspect research aspect
so this field of metagenomics is gaining
insights from
micro microbes and microbiota
has generated like enormous interest and
not just
for academia or academics but also in
industry
so in february 2019 axial therapeutics
in massachusetts
they raised 25 million dollars in
financing to develop therapeutics for
neurodegenerative diseases and
neuropsychiatric
diseases another company is uh
this finch therapeutics in somerville so
they are are developing an oral
microbiome
drug for autism uh spectrum disorder
asd so they are now that was announced
in last year september and they have
raised 90 million uh 90 million dollars
for that so there's a lot of uh research
that is
ongoing and there is a lot of uh
requirement
in industry and for a postdoctoral level
as well for this kind of research
so one of the other aspect is to develop
an understanding of metagenomics
research experience so
so to do that one needs to have a good
understanding of the way
data is prepared so in the context of
the program we will be discussing data
sets that are available for
analysis and study of the role
microbiome
plays in agriculture biomedical research
epidemiological studies of infectious
diseases
such as those
so during the last program and we had
this program in
uh september there were a lot of uh
interesting particip interesting studies
that happened during that program
so that resulted in numerous
independent pro independent projects
some of them are highlighted here
so these projects were then peer
reviewed by experts so that's how it
works
so in towards the end when you know that
how this works and you have an idea and
you want to work on a project
we ask you to submit a proposal so there
are already ongoing projects that you
can join
there are already uh projects on the
educational side that
uh that you can further work on and the
third aspect
is the independent project so many of
these uh researchers who are working on
their own research projects
or they are working in their phd in
their labs uh they have some research
questions that could be addressed
using bioinformatics and that could
actually enhance
their you know publication uh quality
and the quality of research or answer
the questions with a complete
understanding so for that purpose
like many of these researchers submitted
their research proposals
and we went through a peer-reviewed
process by
uh by you know sharing those research
uh proposals to experts and then we got
that feedback from them
and then we kind of analyzed it
ourselves
and then we have a session with the
participants uh discussing their
research proposals so some of those
research proposals were really really
exciting and interesting uh some of them
were about the
international space station and uh the
data that have been collected
in the human missions for other
long-term missions
somewhere uh uh in somewhere some of
them were about finding relationships
between
uh saskof2 and how metagenomics can help
in
understanding the virus toxicology and
transmissibility
so those are some of the aspects of this
program
and without taking much of your time
uh i would just wanted to say that i'm
really excited to be a part of this
collaborative research program and i'm
looking forward to meeting the
participant
to guide through the uh right through
the resources
and then developing logical and
conceptual understanding of the ban
of bioinformatics research so
and to talk more about the program
resources and registration
let me invite biepsha uh to guide you
through
guide us through the process thank you
thank you so much uh dr mohit for such
an insightful
presentation for different parts
of this program we will leverage omics
logic resources
that you can use to learn more about
metagenomics
these will include a synchronous
coursework with theoretical material
quizzes and practical assignments our
cloud-based analytical server
where you can analyze large metagenomic
data
and visualize results the omex logic
code playground where you can practice
coding in rn python
as well as a repository of project
example
so let us start by signing up
to our platform which is the edu t
bio info platform if you already have an
account you can log into the platform
if you do not have an account then you
can either sign in using your
email id or you can utilize any of these
social media logins
to sign into the platform this will get
you
started on your own bi-informatics
journey
the first course that we recommend to
you
is the introduction to metagenomics
which will familiarize you with the
concepts of
metagenomic data analysis
and you can also find the link in the
chat box thank you
aditya for sharing the link you can also
see some of these reviews by
previous participants who have taken
this course so this is a free course
please feel free to create an account
and start taking this course
you will also discover that this comes
in a set of
three courses starting with introduction
to metagenomics metagenomics one and
metagenomics two
and you if you are registered for the
program you will have access to all
three of
them as well as a number of curated
data sets prepared as projects
like the american gut microbiome
gut brain access and the role of
microbes for skin conditions like
acne eczema and more which already elia
and dr mohit has spoken about
let us now talk a little bit more about
the practical analysis
approaches we will cover in the program
like kind to
data 2 pipelines and filo seek
throughout this course you will be given
directions to access the
tbio info platform for bioinformatics
processing and analysis of metagenomic
data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as
data management and analysis cloud
infrastructure
to run bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of
analysis are performed in different
sections of this
multi-omics pipeline
the visual interface of the tibia info
platform will enable users to quickly
build
logical graph of their analysis
and understand each steps significant in
running
this pipeline for interested in
implementing
kindly keep your microphones muted
[Music]
thank you so for those interested in
implementing these pipelines for your
own
we will also offer guidance and
references that can be used to
effectively install all the needed
packages for these pipelines
so behind many of these methods are
scripts written in popular
coding languages such as r and python
these are explained in tutorials you
will have access to on our codomix logic
platform these include beginner
tutorials on data importing
preparation for analysis and standard
visualization of
process data more specialized packages
with publication ready outputs will also
be covered
in more advanced lessons that is why
this program is built to provide
students of
all backgrounds with a clear perspective
on big data
analytics machine learning and
artificial intelligence in
application to omics data and research
clinical and industry applications
our omics logic step-by-step process is
enabled by
access to complex tools via a simple and
intuitive interface at the same time
exposing participants to analysis logic
in the context of real data sets and
extrapolation of this logic
to a variety of projects and data sets
with assistance from mentors
and technical support now let us take a
look at some participants from our
recent
bioinformatics training programs in
nigeria
who have been very successful here you
can see farida bashar
who has gained over 10 000 points
and have completed multiple courses
denoted by the course certificates
so the free course that we have shared
also comes with a certificate of its own
so if you are looking forward to earn a
certificate
you can complete introduction to
metagenomics and you will be earning a
certificate
like foreign mojib is also working
towards completing the courses
and as you can see in both these cases
the participants have
a complete profile so once you are
logged into edut bio info the first step
is to update your profile and an updated
profile comes with a full
picture and your full name as this is
the name which will be reflected
in the asynchronous course certificate
that you would be getting
and you can also learn more about these
participants via the edu link
so you can also be one of those
participants who are featured in
one of our webinars in our social media
channel so please feel free
to make sure that your profile is
updated and
aditya has also shared all of the
profiles of these two participants
your achievements in the program are
denoted by the points
as we saw in the last two slides so once
you complete
this training you will receive either a
certificate of
excellence or a certificate of
completion depending on the number of
points you achieve
and this is an effective tracking
mechanism
why because the points you receive are
not only from the course work that you
do
but also by running pipelines on the tbi
or info server
or by using the codomix logic platform
for running the codes
so all of these platforms are linked
together so all of your activity is
tracked and they add to your points
so you or as well as your faculty
or even if you are coming as part of a
university can track your progress
even our mentor team can track your
progress
to start with the program please
register on the edut bio info portal
and once you are signed in we will be
sending you a link
that will ask you to register for the
program
and you can visit that link to complete
your registration
now the cost of this program is 150
usd and we understand that
this may not be an affordable option for
a lot of participants here
so we also have a scholarship option for
students
you would need to complete the necessary
requirements to be
awarded the scholarship please start by
filling out the form that you will see
in the chat box if you are interested in
applying for this one month
training program and now
i'm going to be opening this session for
questions
and also i would like to ask you all
to see a poll right now on your screen
where we would want to know more about
you so the first
question here is what is your
educational background
the second question is what are your
areas of research interest
so we do know that a lot of you are
interested in metagenomics research but
you may also be interested in either of
these
research areas so please feel free to
share
and the third question is where are you
from
so i will keep the poll on and we would
try to address any questions that you
may have
so i see that a lot of the questions
that came
in are regarding the different resources
or if you can get started if you are a
beginner yes
you can definitely get started with this
program
even if you are a beginner because we
will start with basic courses like
introduction to metagenomics which will
give you an
overview of this full metagenomic
training
and metagenomic data analysis
uh can you see the poll on the screen
yes we can see the power jay kitchen are
you not able to see the poll on the
screen
okay so i'll keep it on for a few more
minutes and if you have
any other questions then you can please
put them down in the chat box
and again this session is open for
everyone uh to participate in so
please go ahead and complete your
registration we do not have a long time
before
february 16 so we would be starting it
next week so thank you again
for making time to join today's session
yes so after we leave uh i would like to
just there was a question on how to
get access to the platform so maybe i
could just
explain how that would work
sure yeah so should i stop sharing my
screen
yes please
so the server platform
offers a cloud based
account where you can store large data
sets
you can import data sets directly from
ncbi
upload your own fastq files and reuse
them multiple times
and also analyze process
and interpret the results so first of
all when you get to this platform
you will see this link right here in the
menu that says
access so we need to do is
fill out your name that information
comes to us by email
and we will review your application and
send you the details
and there are three different options to
use this
the first one is the free option so
using the free
option you understand how different
sections of this platform
operate and what types of outputs
and inputs they utilize for example
since we're talking about metagenomics
here we have a demo pipeline for one of
the data sets that we will discuss in
detail during the program
it is a data two processing pipeline
with interpretation using filoseek which
is a package in
r so you start the pipeline by clicking
on start
here you have a little explanation of
what the
overall idea behind this pipeline is
then the data 2 pipeline consists of
number of different steps
that are specifically designed to
eliminate the noise
in the data and make sure that the
result the output
is cleared from all of the contamination
because you're talking about many
different unannotated reads
from a whole variety of different
microbes
finally when the data is analyzed
based on a database called the silva
database
now you can study what is the
relationship between
different groups of reads based on their
taxonomic
association using a phylogenetic
analysis called
ape which produces biome files
that could be visualized and further
analyzed for their composition
using this package called phyloseq
so finally when your data is processed
and analyzed
you will see some pipeline outputs and
you can really see what to expect
so what are these otus what is the
taxonomy table
what are the different plots that you
can get from phyloseq etc
so this is an example for the free tier
you anyone can register and get this
demo pipeline for free you can see a
variety of different examples
including the microbiome transcriptome
genomic data analysis mass spec
structural biology
data integration and modeling data
mining and machine learning
and other specific pro processing
pipelines for
virology such as different strains in
cobit 19 detection of mutations
and things like that so this is a
full-fledged bioinformatics analysis
platform
that will allow you to process
analyze and visualize your onyx data
now included with this as i already
mentioned
are some packages in r and python that
you could
learn how to read modify and adapt
to whatever you want to do with them
also learning
how to code along the way and so the
second resource that beeps
demonstrated with it was the code
omixlogic
playground and here we also have a
section dedicated to metagenomics
so this is going to be covered again
extensively in the program itself
but you will learn how to perform
analysis of sequences
visualization composition statistical
analysis and a number of
other things that are critical for
anyone that wants to learn how to make
the most out of their microbiome data
so the unique part of this is that you
actually get to see
the code and try to run it yourself
so you learn about the code you see the
different outputs
and then you can actually try it by
yourself
so here we have created a way for us to
uh take the scripts and run them
in our studio on the cloud and really
eliminates a lot of the
challenges that people have with
setting up their environment so here for
example you can see i've analyzed the
data set
and i can see the composition of my
sample
based on proportion or based on
abundance
so this is a little bit of an overview
of some of these tools and how to
register again many of these resources
are completely free
so if you don't want to join the program
and you don't have maybe
the time or you want to do this on your
own pace
you can register here for free start
learning and when the time comes you
will see
different types of additional in-depth
uh resources like actual research
uh capabilities of the platform where
you can upload your own data and manage
it using
ftp uh and on the coding
we also have some advanced course work
like machine learning and data science
that could get you farther along with
the data that you have
thank you alia so there is a question
from iodine
is it possible for one to jump directly
on the core metagenomics where we can
use the actual r scripts
yeah so as i showed uh the same r
scripts
are offered there in any kind of
processing
of data it's not the scripts
that typically limit you it's the
infrastructure so if the data is big
and many of the current studies include
hundreds if not
thousands of samples and the analysis
you can do them on your computer but
unless you have a server stack
you're going to be waiting for a long
time for those pipelines to finish so
that's why we have a lot of these
pipelines implemented on our big data
high performance computing
infrastructure
for you to be able to work with real
data sets but once the data sets are
percent processed and they're ready as a
table
you can then do the downstream analysis
and visualization
in r and in python and that is a big
part of what we will do in the program
as well
first of all understanding the logic why
are we doing what we are doing
and what do these visualizations mean
and then doing it
ourselves in our and learning how to
manipulate the data
wrangle it and visualize and interpret
thank you so much elia so i would want
you all to
go ahead and join our social media
groups
so we are having an active group in
linkedin
and if you go through the group you can
see that this is a group not only for
students or researchers but
you would see that there are a lot of uh
scientists who are joining us in this
group from all
around the world so this gives an
opportunity to be part of a larger
community
as well as we have a group in facebook
so whichever platform
is easy for you please go ahead and join
our platforms
and now to clear some of the doubts that
a lot of you are having regarding the
registration
so if you are already registered on edut
bio info i'm putting the link in the
chat
then this is the link to check out so
you can note
that here is a 150 dollar the price
there is a 33 percent discount that
would be emailed to you
if you have already shared your email id
or
if you were already registered for this
program
so you would have to check out via this
link and you can also see the different
courses
that are included as part of this
training program
so please visit this link and if you are
someone who is looking for a scholarship
i
require a scholarship here is a
scholarship form again
i'm posting it here in the chat box so
please make sure to fill up
each of these fields in the scholarship
form and maybe let us take a look at
this together
so that we know what are the different
things that we have to
fill up here so you see you have email
first name last name the company
an organization your current level of
education graduation year
currency gpa any other awards
and the reason you're applying for the
scholarship you have to upload your cv
and please make sure that you're also
mentioning a reference from your college
or university
and also this field so all of these
fields should be filled up for that
scholarship to be accepted and once that
scholarship is accepted
or we want to discuss more with you we
would set up a meeting with you
and your reference so please make sure
to mention
the correct name and email addresses of
your references
will set up that meeting and that
meeting will decide
whether that scholarship is going to be
given to you
so please go through this process and if
you are joining us directly please
follow these link
and we will also be sending you this
entire link to join the program and send
you an email with all the details about
the program
and this scholarship may either be a
full scholarship or only a partial
scholarship that would be decided
while you're having that conversation
with you and your reference
so it would be uh dependent on that
meeting that we have with you
and i'm moving on i would also want to
highlight two more programs that we are
having very soon so this program is
again
a specialized training on precision
oncology
so here is the link again
if someone is interested in joining this
program
this is starting on march 15th and we
also have an
ongoing program for researchers and
students
who are interested in working on their
own project so this is either a three
months or a six months project
development program
where we work closely with a student
to help them work on their own novel
project
and our team of mentor guides that
student right from the training
to the completion of that project so
if you are joining like a three months
program
we are here to make sure that you can
come up with a project of your own
and of course you would have to give in
quite some time of yours
to be able to come up with a novel
project while if you are also intending
to go beyond just a project and aim
towards say a poster presentation
or even working on a publication which
can be a very long drawn out process
so we definitely recommend six months or
more
to be able to make sure that that
project is ready to be presented
to everyone else so this is again
another one of the offerings that are
available for students
clinicians or researchers who are
interested
in attending a research program like
this
and with this i would like to thank you
all for attending today's session
and i hope you enjoyed this session and
it was informative to you
and hope to see you in the upcoming week
in the
microbiome and metagenomic data analysis
program
thank you everyone
you